salut romain ça non c'est la gueule de
bois
je comprends pas pourquoi ça a peut-être
un lien que les neuf films d'alcool que
tu t'es enfilé hier soir non tu crois ok
si comme romain et moi même vous aimait
boire un verre avec vos amis le soir
venu vous connaissez forcément ce
sympathique est à cenon qu'on appelle la
gueule de bois
et comme il faut connaître son ennemi
pour mieux le combattre on va se pencher
un peu sur la question
l'expression gueule de bois viendrait du
fait d'avoir la bouche sèche comme du
bois un rendement de soirée trop arrosée
mais c'est loin d'être le seul
désagrément de la situation et c'est
même le plus gentil hier à dire meilleur
depuis on a trouvé d'autres termes pour
décrire ce syndrome comme l'asile aux
tomates par exemple ça claque un bep en
vrai xylo en grec se veut juste dire
bois estomac cela veut dire bouche
ottonello quand même ça pourra au
sérieux bonjour patron désolé d'être en
retard mais j'ai eu de gueule de bois
tu te fous de moi alors tu me rends ton
bac ton flingue et tu dégages bonjour
patron désolé shore tard j'ai une
psychose tobias emmerdes au nom pour
vieux ça c'est la tuile ça prend
quelques jours pour soigner cette
saloperie c'est moi qui autres termes
plus récent encore pour désigner la
gueule de bois
la veisalgie alors ça vient du norvégien
mais il est vrai que price veulent plus
bon ça veut dire malaise ou inconfort
suivant la débauche avec en plus la
racine grecque
alger à albi qui veut dire d'où leur bon
mais derrière les mots il ya la
souffrance et à moins de préférer penser
que c'est une espèce de châtiment divin
vous avez sûrement envie de savoir ce
qui se passe dans votre corps un
lendemain de cuite et ben en réalité la
torture imposé par la gueule de bois
elles s'expliquent principalement par
les efforts que fait votre corps pour
éliminer l'alcool et elle commence quand
sont tous dans le sens approche 0
pourquoi il faut aller chercher la
réponse du côté de notre foi c'est lui
qui est chargé d'éliminer 90% de
l'alcool qu'on s'envoie et lui faut
environ une heure trente pour éliminer
un verre mais c'est après que le plus
dur commence
une fois dégradé par le foie l'alcool se
transforme en acétaldéhyde
une substance toxique et cancérigène en
plus elle s'accumule dans l'organisme et
elle est responsable de symptômes comme
les maux de tête les nausées les
vomissements ou les tremblements et
c'est encore au foie que revient la
tâche d'éliminer cette acétaldéhyde mais
le problème c'est que ça se fait très
lentement parce qu'il n'est équipé que
pour en traiter une toute petite
quantité
quand on boit de l'alcool notre
organisme demande aussi un petit effort
à nos reins pour chasser l'intrus il
élimine plus d'eau que d'habitude c'est
pour ça qu'on fait + pipi c'est ce qui
explique ce qui pourrait passer pour un
paradoxe plus on voit plus on est
déshydratée ou parce qu'on n'y aurait
plus de liquide qu'on envoie en réalité
et du coup le corps va puiser dans ses
réserves d'eau personnel et notamment
dans celle du cerveau et ça ça pique je
suis pas sûr que ce soit très clair je
vais vous montrer plus tôt ça c'est
votre cerveau en temps normal et ça
c'est votre cerveau un lendemain de
cuite
bon je caricature un peu en mêle vous
avez l'idée cette déshydratation est
notamment responsable des maux de tête
mais aussi des crampes musculaires
l'alcool lui-même et la déshydratation
font aussi du mal à vos sinus ce qui
donne cette espèce de douleur du visage
vraiment caractéristique vous savez de
quoi je parle autre responsable du
malaise des substances chimiques qu'on
appelle les congénères et qui viennent
de la fermentation d'alcool ou qui sont
ajoutés dans artificiellement y en a
plus dans les alcools brin que dans les
alcools blancs et aussi dans les alcools
de mauvaise qualité
pour finir sachez que si l'alcool aide à
s'endormir il détériore sérieusement la
qualité du sommeil en perturbant ses
cycles et en aggravant les troubles du
sommeil notamment ceux qui sont liés à
la respiration comme les apnées où les
ronflements et là aussi vous savez de
quoi je parle il réduit aussi ce qu'on
appelle le sommeil paradoxal pendant
lequel le cerveau remet un petit peu
d'ordre dans ses affaires c'est ce qui
explique la fatigue extrême et la
confusion les jours de gueule de bois
alors vous allez me demander mais qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire donc tu
vas sur cette blague à chaque fois en
fait les dlc de boire moins mais si vous
étiez capable de résister à l'appel de
l'alcool on en serait pas là en train de
parler de ça donc je vais quand même
vous donner deux trois trucs avant la
soirée d'abord manger tout simplement
avant d'aller faire la fête faites vous
un bon repas bien consistant riche en
protéines et en sucres lents genre
bonne plâtrée pâte avec un petit conseil
quand même au moment de choisir votre
menu souvenez vous il ya une petite
chance pour que ce que vous allez manger
ça revienne nous faire un petit coucou
pendant la soirée
pendant la soirée buvez mais pas que de
l'alcool quatre verres d'alcool ça vous
fait perdre 1 litre d'eau donc entre
chaque vers prenez une boisson non
alcoolisée de préférence de l'eau ou un
jus de fruits parce que le fructose ça
aide à éliminer l'alcool mais aussi
l'acétaldéhyde dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure
choisissez ce que vous buvez plutôt de
la bière ou des alcools blancs et de
préférence de bonne qualité ah oui et le
coût des mélanges qui rendent malades
ces légendes urbaines ce le lendemain
bon on y est vous avez fait n'importe
quoi vous avez la gueule de bois mais
vous pouvez encore limité la casse avec
avant commençait très important prenez
une pastilles à la menthe
on avait une loque toute la journée vous
allez avoir besoin dead et personne
n'acceptera de vous approcher tant que
vous aurez cette allen de bizet boucher
ensuite là encore buvez de l'eau pour
lutter contre la déshydratation
par petit verre si vous êtes moyennement
serein digestive mans parlant mais
régulièrement
vous pouvez aussi boire des tisanes des
bouillons salé ou un peu de jus de
tomate par contre limiter le thé ou le
café parce que ça aggrave la
déshydratation et ça accélère le rythme
cardiaque
il est déjà mis à rude épreuve par votre
état un peu de sucre est aussi pour
lutter contre l'hypoglycémie le soda
c'est pas mal et notamment le sprite
apparemment selon une étude chinoise
alors si vous retirez les bulles c'est
encore mieux oui parce que bon alors par
contre le coût de soigner le mal par le
mal
oubliez tout de suite revoir un verre
d'alcool ça a peut-être vous soulager
deux minutes mais ça va surtout redonner
du travail à votre foi et il a vraiment
autre chose à faire avec ça c'est
vraiment toi d'affaires manger aussi
mais pas n'importe quoi
désolé mais le coût du kebab ou du
groupe burger bien gracq éponge tout bas
c'est mito aussi bah oui parce que
deviner qui est chargée d'éliminer les
graisses
c'est moi et j'ai vraiment autre chose à
faire laissez-le bosser tranquille et
manger plutôt des trucs qui se digère
facilement comme du blanc de poulet du
pain des légumes des yaourts des fruits
genre des bananes à et éviter tout ce
qui est acide un as touché c'est bien
aussi
et si vous aimez le miel vous privez pas
et petit conseil avant de manger
prenez un citrate de bétaïne ça il est
re à des drames alors comme tout ça ça
suffit rarement vous allez sûrement être
tentés de prendre des médicaments
mais le problème c'est que l'aspirine et
l'ibuprofène c'est mauvais pour
l'estomac
et le paracétamol comme le doliprane par
exemple pas à lié à l'alcool c'est
toxique pour le foie
prenez plutôt une bonne douche bien
chaude et dès que vous vous en sentez
capable aller faire un petit tour à pied
pour vous réveiller alors pas la peine
de courir un semi-marathon non plus vous
allez pas éliminer plus vite par contre
vous risquez de vous choper des jolis
chronos alors on est d'accord le
meilleur moyen d'éviter la gueule de
bois ça reste de boire peu et c'est
surtout meilleur moyen d'éviter tout le
reste
parce que l'alcool ces responsables de
40 à 50 mille morts chaque année en
france et c'est la deuxième cause de
mortalité évitable
après le tabac au kg ch et l'ambiance
mais pensez-y quand même pour le reste
et parce qu'on sait tous que vous avez
quand même continuer à faire la fête là
maintenant vous savez quoi faire
vous avez des questions à me poser sur
ce sujet ou sur un autre qui concerne le
corps humain laissez moi un commentaire
et on en reparle en attendant abonnez
vous pour rien rater et à bientôt
où ça la dtc